well we didn't get to celebrate
yesterday so we are today the five
turned eight and to kick off the party
we're taking a look back at the past
year this is a Fox News Alert again
robert muller has submitted his report
on the russia investigation to a trainer
general william bar fox news alert an
explosive college admissions scandal
control of congress is up for grabs as
millions of americans cast their ballots
in what's shaping up to be historic
midterm elections jesse smollett now
faces a felony charge for filing a false
report claiming that he was a victim you
are looking live at a massive fire
engulfing the historic notre-dame
Cathedral in Paris France
Fox News Alert President Trump has
ordered the FBI to conduct an
investigation into Judge Cavanaugh
[Music]
Bell dinging
[Music]
[Music]
ain't nothing but a big pile of dirty
tricks after John Rich performed our
song shut up about politics on the show
yesterday it reached number one on the
iTunes country charts and number two
overall I figured that I would try to
put the abundant while being blindfolded
because it what it does is when you're
blindfolded it accentuates all your
other senses of animation I'd a new
recipe yes I got off the Internet's yes
and they said it would be like Chili's
Bar and Grill for the coke they have
great queso there yeah so I thought I
would try it
hi I injured myself chasing people
around with the reptile even going into
the wall you know what it's time for
yeah
animals are great great you're gonna be
so sick of this I was in Texas that's
all they talk about animals are great
and why not because they are great so
are you as angry as I am that there are
no animals are great video on today I'm
on the street kids come up to me and say
animals are great
I say get away from me kid permission to
make an analogy Greg permission to make
an analogy correctable permission to
make an analogy permission to make an
analogy sure permission to make an
analogy Greg yes Jesse guess what guess
what but guess what guess what guess
what guess what guess what guess what
guess what guess what guess what guess
what we've done this past year the guess
what thing I was pretty funny it was
pretty funny we actually have a cake
there was a cake because you know can't
have Friday and an anniversary without a
cake that's pretty good I think we have
another cake we have to have another
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hey can you something on every milestone
I read the review of the five when the
five came out by I'm not going to say
the name the publication or the writer
but effin 7c is apparently out of new
ideas and unsure of a future course the
Fox had months to prepare for the day
and this is the best it could come up
with this is a rare public manifestation
of scramble mode I lost the last page it
says I predict this show will not last
yes he said it was a band-aid he said it
was a band-aid yeah it was a band-aid
the last eight years it jerk taken by
the cake thing idea I was acting oh you
saw originally cake to say before we go
that we should thank the audience
because you know nothing lasts for eight
years a long time so thank you for
watching thank you for taking us into
your house while you're cooking dinner
having a drink to the gym laughing with
all of us just think to all our
arguments